islamist militants have killed dozens of
civilians in northern mozambique
an armed group is holding the town of
palma under siege
it is a hub for international gas
projects worth some 60 billion dollars
the mozambique government says hundreds
of local people and foreign workers have
been rescued
and the french energy group total has
suspended work on a huge construction
project
mozambique's defense ministry says it is
working to restore normality
the defense and security forces
reinforced their operational strategy to
contain the terrorists criminal attacks
and restore normality in palmer
they've carried out operational actions
in the last three days focused primarily
on the rescue of hundreds of national
and foreign citizens protection of
citizens
and their property
dw correspondent adrian kries was in
mozambique before the
latest fighting began and is following
developments from cape town
he sent us this update about the
situation in palma
we have a very poor part of the country
actually the poorest part of the country
a lot of people are unhappy that the
government is not
investing and the government is not
listening to them then few of them
radicalize and the security forces
respond with massive force
also attacking their families and people
who have nothing to do
with those radical people and hence they
radicalize more people so the whole
thing spiraled out of control and
although the government has been busy
over the past months to say well
everything is under control it is not
they've basically just been quite
successful in keeping journalists out
and
international observers from the area
but the situation is bad when we finally
managed to get there last month
we had terrifying stories from displaced
people in the camps there
you heard stories of children who were
taken away
father showed me the picture of a 16
year old daughter and said look they
just took her away
one year ago i haven't heard anything of
her you hear stories of decapitating of
villagers in front of the entire village
and
this has been happening for many months
it is still not clear though
what the group really wants but it
appears that it's much more about
power and influence than it is about
religion